[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
it's early it's cold it's New York City
we're having a couple of coffees
yes great movie
oh yeah dude I'm [ __ ] I mean I went
after it this weekend I drank too much
same yeah I left Wednesday got home last
night at 11 p.m from where Buffalo it's
a long story we got a lot to talk about
love buffalo all right well you go to
chefs I didn't go to [ __ ] I never heard
of chefs Santa Monica pull it up look at
that look at that [ __ ] pasta I don't
even know what I'm looking at here
that's a brick of cheese over pasta that
sauce is next level
that chefs in Buffalo I got love for
Buffalo I like Buffalo good Italian
Community good people good people hard
nose ice cold salt of the earth but look
at this today this is what got Peter's
in his shape this is out of control I
ate that before I went on stage
this ain't good oh man that's worse than
already Lang doing heroin before going
out it's just wage it out a lot of women
look like on Tinder in Buffalo
Jesus that's true how are you like now
we love you already we love you all
right funny guy the best he has one of
my favorite jokes uh he's uh talking
about
what's the guy's name who's dating Khloe
Kardashian Odom yeah he was yeah yeah so
he's in the kitchen at the house and at
like three in the morning uh like making
a sandwich and he's like uh he's like oh
man this religious relationship with
these women there's too many of these
women I might start doing crack and
Bruce Jenner walks down and goes wait to
hear what I'm gonna do that's a great
joke I might have [ __ ] it up no you
can't that's a great I love the one he
did about you know all the NBA people
were like stay in school and then like
he's like yeah yes go to college instead
of getting millions of dollars in the
NBA he's like that's why instead of if
they want to say stay in school instead
of a dunk contest an All-Star weekend
they should do a spelling bee
because what would you rather see them
dunk again or Stefan Marbury try to
spell Wednesday oh oh that's a great
joke he's so perfect everything about
that is that's great damn he's good
spelling bee then you have the visual of
these giant seven foot dudes at a
spelling bee with the name tag gold
hilarious you got another one it's like
uh I never use the n-word unless it's
the fourth quarter
only he can get away with that [ __ ] he's
like that age is like grandfathered in
those jokes right right yeah he's a
great great dude too I miss him oh yeah
I hope we see him around again soon oh
yeah one of the funny great book too fat
to fish incredible so funny yeah so
funny also him on Stern arguing with
Dice Clay is one of the all-time great
radio moments yeah he used to say
something about how he used to wait
three hours in line to see Dice and now
he Dodges his phone calls yes exactly
exactly dice tried to get money out of
him it's a whole thing wow but that's
Showbiz it can just keep going and then
now you're fighting with your Heroes so
tell me about Buffalo all right so
Wednesday got a gig in Toronto Danforth
theater what an amazing place did that
beautiful city too great City great
comedy Town Toronto so we're at the
theater and I'm just chatting with the
comics and they're like so what do you
got tomorrow I'm like I'm going to
Buffalo they're like oh that's a quick
flight or quick drive and I was like
yeah let me look that up I'm connecting
at seven in the morning to DC and then
going up back to Buffalo and I text my
manager like what the hell is this and I
got the road guy on it everybody's on it
like yeah what is that that's crazy he's
like there's nothing left
so Rob Mayu
of a royal comedy
Club he's like hey this guy will drive
you give him a couple hundred bucks I
said I'll give you 200 bucks you drive
me he's like we'll go tomorrow at noon
we had a great day but
Jacob Second Adventure every week I know
so I had to cancel my flights I get in
the car with this guy and we're about to
cross the border and he goes you don't
have any drugs do you and I go well I
use Edibles to sleep and he goes get rid
of them get rid of it we're gonna get
killed over there they're gonna rape us
they're gonna kill us scalp us so I go
all right so we pull over if they did
rape you but what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
we have to we're sorry it's sorry
so I'm like [ __ ] so now we pull over to
guy's house like a block before the
Border just some random guy's house I'm
going through my bag I got a million
Edibles in there shrooms I just
forgotten about it must have been like
thousands of dollars worth of
merchandise oh my God we throw in some
guy's lawn it must be painful brutal bro
I hate throwing [ __ ] away and then this
kid Jacob is like like what are you
doing he's like I'm writing the address
when I come back over I'm getting these
I was like it's like Fargo I know funny
looking guy so uh
we go over the Border they go uh where
you go what do you got there go passport
they go all right get through it I'm
like
so he did the right thing but they
didn't check anyway damn brutal so sucks
but the gigs were great gigs were great
get the Buffalo uh Sean over there is
great we had a Jordan Fisher opening oh
yeah I like him uh Kyle Turner hosting
we had a great time six shows sold out
killer crowd sold merch then
a guy goes hey I work with the bills I
got your number from Shane Gillis I'm
the personal trainer you want to come to
the game on Sunday
I'd have to move my flight but all right
yeah okay so I called Sean Murphy he's a
bills guy he's like I'm flying up I got
tickets for everybody I assume we're
gonna be in a big box it's gonna be
great
13th row in the snow freezing my tits
off no coat I don't have a coat in
Buffalo well I was there for three days
I got I got like a bomber jacket and uh
so I had to get a coat I had to get a
giant parka I got it though did you get
a nice coat well I borrowed one from
this guy it was very nice but now you're
just shivering it I'm like damn I
thought we're gonna be in a box I
thought we were gonna be shaking hands
with uh Gabe and the other guy Josh
Allen and we were out in the snow
and it was hell I have a whole new
respect for Buffalo people any town that
goes out and supports in the snow like
that those were like blankets out there
and stuff it's insane and they're
hooting and Hauling and drunk at 7am
they're tailgating they do yeah but
that's a strong group of whites over
there that's a great football town and
oh yeah they got a great team did they
win I think they won I bailed early I
was like I gotta get out of here I can't
feel my hands
it's amazing I was the diva I was like
all right I don't live here I never used
to do that [ __ ] but we were in Kansas
City a couple weeks ago and I did check
if the chiefs were playing because I got
my home so I'm like I got it yeah I can
see it live I'm I told veto I was like
we're going [ __ ] you [ __ ] your second
baby dude
we've seen some foosball yeah it's fun
but when it's cold I don't know how
people do it yeah dude it's tough tough
the women out there just like it's a
great part you know it's crazy it's a
lot of scary people up there but they're
good eggs and they love their team and
they live for it you realize how good we
have it when you watch these people
rooting for these teams you're like they
need this yeah this is like important
Buffalo's got an identity and culture I
feel like a lot there's some other
cities in that area where you're like
this ain't this ain't right oh yeah
Syracuse that's a stinker Rochester's
Rochester's got some moments it's got
moments but I do remember nearly like we
were veter and I were like we'll take a
walk and then and we I'm like dude oh
yeah there's dealers on every corner we
will get robbed definitely this is not
and yeah and I told them like yeah you
100 would have been robbed if you took
that walk oh yeah it's uh it's one of
those block to block you're like this is
beautiful look at these old home John
Kodak lived there then you go to to uh
right now for him yeah and you're like
the guy they'd name drop as their dude
I'm like they're like yeah he commits
suicide
is the guy this is your guy his rumors
he was gay never married no pictures
though
the irony it's a Kodak moment when he
was hanging all right well
well you guys got sad there what about
you where were you I was in the city
this week I had to wear a weekend in the
city just at Cellar spots Great nice
lots of fun killer in a week different
uh for the weekend for you there because
you're there during the week so often
but playing a weekend show does it feel
different to you yeah you know the
village has an energy on the weekends oh
yeah
it's great you know yeah move down there
so I'm like walking home now so it's
it's not oh that's right yeah what an
apartment by the way have you been yeah
come by I almost blew you I mean it is a
panty drop dude I don't know is that
close I was oh I was good that's why I
had to leave I was like all right I
faked a phone call I was up I was
already on one I was Kaepernick speaking
of my new place I got a wreck for you uh
Peters can you pull this up yeah
or Salamanca Whoever has it
got one of them uh Toto Toilets Toto
toilet cleans the butthole drives the
butthole bidet a bidet yeah and uh yeah
the toilet seats dude really is the
other video
it was a video is it up Sam it's of me
taking a [ __ ] oh great I want you to see
it airdrop coming in all right good wow
now did you install this of course not
what are you are you kidding me no it's
like pipes and stuff involved I'm
useless all right I paid a guy to do it
but there it is uh yeah let's see look
at this bad boy Whoa in action you're
sitting on a computer here dude look at
this thing it's got lights and buttons
look at that
there we go
in and out motion oh hell yeah that's
dangerous they're gonna hit the sack oh
no it doesn't doesn't you you it's in
the right place all right yeah it's I
mean that's a strong stream too really
the other day I came
really seems to care
all right all right I gotta get one of
these everybody get one dude you got one
no it's also I mean like even if it
weren't eco-friendly I'd be into this
but it is so you're like yeah it's kind
of cool enough to buy toilet paper
anymore yeah your ass is Green Oh my ass
is green baby mine's pink I'm I'm wiping
too much I'm bleeding down there I get
the red paper now now anytime I'm gonna
have to take a [ __ ] like a hotel I'm
gonna be like ah I know
it sucks it feels very primitive and
also you know the wiping in the winter
there's something gross about you know
yeah this is crazy old butthole yeah I
want people to come over and take a [ __ ]
take it for a test spin if you're not I
would love to yeah come by I can [ __ ]
and blow you same time yeah yeah we're
both getting squirted I squirt on both
ends I'm friends with this girl for 15
years and I just went to her apartment
and she and I went to take a leak and
she had one of those
and I was like I've learned more about
you in these two seconds than I've
learned in our 15 years why someone in
this house eats ass and I didn't know
that do you think that someone
definitely eats acid they have that
toilet I think so I think it's a big
part of it yeah
interesting oh yeah you're cleaning
house you know that's not why I got it
but I mean definitely a bonus well
that's a bonus you're about to join the
club I don't know I'd hate to see that
ass crack just cut by the eyebrows alone
my butthole looks like Uncle Fester's
face but the crack is like Quest love
it's gonna pick in there yeah I said I
said we made the same I'm an idiot but
yeah yeah oh and I saw the the
Charlemagne video tell us about that it
was a killer clip oh pull it up Dr Umar
yes yeah that was three it was you and
two guys from MSG yeah it was uh I wish
there was just two people on a panel
just because like you get like not that
much time on the show Sean Wayne's a
great host I mean uh he's such a uh no
it's not a story he's a great host but
you get oh that's Brandi Chastain we had
her on the other pod the you know uh
scored the game-winning goal for Team
USA in the in the 90s oh wow rules yeah
that's cool against China
no don't play this you want to get taken
down for that there it is right there
the third one this year yeah oh yeah
we're gonna have to play the whole oh
yeah you don't have to play it it's just
cool no but uh no don't play I don't
play it but uh yeah it was it was mad
fun dude it was Comedy Central it's
crazy it's like that was the last that
was Trevor Noah's last night so we came
on after him and he was going on and on
I was like oh boy come on really I mean
they lost Trevor Noah now they're gonna
have a guest host I guess yeah yeah
they're gonna have Franken
that'll be interesting huh huh
what's that now
um but yeah
well that's so it's kind of there's a
live audience there and that's old
that's kind of old school it's funny
people I love that because we're so used
to that that's like our comfort zone we
kind of have to be on oh yeah I wasn't
so much freaking
uh methylphenidate what the hell does
that mean like concentrated Ritalin whoa
what's popping what what were you just
hung over no I just [ __ ] I get
nervous when they keep changing the
topics day of and I want to have some
jokes in my head locked and loaded just
in case whichever way they go uh-huh but
uh
I took him you know I was sick last week
too [ __ ] there's everyone's getting sick
here man yeah something's going around
but let me just say it was cool because
I was watching you tweet jokes about
Griner when she got released and then I
saw the show and it was a lot of the
same stuff and that's so cool to see the
process yeah that's what we all do I
know but it's funny it should be the
other way around you should be doing the
jokes on stage and then tweeting because
we have more followers on the social
media than the 100 people you're
performing for whatever the seller but
yeah but we you know we don't give a
[ __ ] about the Tweet you know the tweets
so it's like this yeah that's the
workout for the stage it's an open mic
basically what uh were you this weekend
uh I guess we're back is this our New
Year's app oh geez jeez we're gonna
we're gonna be ready for this New Year's
I put together what do you got so the
lady she did the whole wedding she
killed it it was amazing yeah you guys
were there so she's like you suck I hate
you I'm done mic drop you gotta do the
honeymoon and I said ah ah [ __ ] all
right all right fair is fair
so
we're going to Africa as I mentioned but
the dates got all [ __ ] up because I'm
booking it so there's like an open gap
for three days before we go and I said
[ __ ] it we're going to Amsterdam so I
just booked two two tickets to Amsterdam
so you're going from Amsterdam to Africa
yes is that how is that routing not
great
we gotta go through DC then up to
Buffalo no but uh some weird guys
driving it yeah we got a guy on a boat
some open Miker you don't have to throw
away the Edibles from Amsterdam though
ah good point good point but she's like
ah so I let you decide where we go and
it's just right to horse
that's pretty good that'll be fun yeah
mixes it up but you couldn't be more
different Africa Amsterdam that'll be
exactly exactly is she excited for that
oh yeah we've always wanted to go the
canals the weed cakes the bikes the
people tallest people in the world Dutch
really yeah
well they're white they tend to be I'm
sure there's a Dutch NBA Rick Smith's
Dutch
Dutchman they call him the Flying
Dutchman yeah there you go
and Dutch you think they hate that
I wonder go in Dutch that must be from
them yeah so I think I figured this out
I didn't look this up at all but going
dutch I think means split yeah yes Dutch
doors split oh we're going dutch we're
splitting the bill
there's another one too give it a [ __ ]
that's pretty good I think that means
what does that mean someone gives you
money this Dutch oven Dutch oven with
fart under a blanket with a with a kid
here
but it's kind of a harmless crime it's
just a scent
yeah that's always like when you've been
in a relationship too long and you're
just like I don't give a [ __ ] and you do
it and they're like what the [ __ ]
and you're like that was for me every
once in a while it's for me yeah that's
the difference between men and women
right there it is amazing how like early
on the relationship you just won't fart
and then cut to like two months you're
[ __ ] with the door open it really is
amazing completely the comfort zone
where you're just like I don't care yeah
I'll be [ __ ] and I'm like can you
hand me my phone and she's like there
you go you know
oh yeah wow
first date I don't know that's tough
depends on the girl I gotta feel it out
but yeah sometimes girls love it
sometimes like Michelle wolf if you fart
around her she is on the floor she's
like what's your comic she's a comic but
some girls are like all right I gotta go
this is crazy
yeah oh I got another [ __ ] wreck for
you New York City winter Sichuan Chinese
oh get a little braised fish with chili
sauce went with my brother the other day
and uh
oh my God if you [ __ ] find a Sichuan
spot I love Szechuan I mean we three of
us have done it a decent amount oh yeah
look at that spice now is this Christmas
day oh I'll be doing a Christmas Day for
sure watching
um all day basketball you better believe
it I got another I got a pee for you
that goes off this too I was with my
brother the other night you ever run
into someone
and they uh and you say oh this is the
bottom of the cellar with me and I go oh
there's my brother and they go I didn't
know you had a brother you've never
mentioned it oh yeah you've never and
it's like who is this for
right right you're not making either of
us feel good here right right yeah you
know I mean he's uncomfortable I'm
uncomfortable yeah I've never ever
mentioned it's almost like he doesn't
matter to you and he doesn't exist it's
also calling out your relationship with
your friend like we're not close enough
that I would tell you I have a brother
nothing good comes of it yeah nothing
but people do that [ __ ] a lot
isn't that weird they really do yeah
I've had people do that with girlfriends
they're like you have a girlfriend
you've never mentioned her I'm like
this is my other girlfriend yeah and
she's like what are you talking about
and I'm like
second date
we're making moves
all right but yeah people do that that's
approve that's real good peeve peeve
could be a bit there I I got some Wicked
people let me just say as a wreck since
we talked about men and women Neil
Brennan special he's got one of my
favorite jokes I've ever heard about
he's talking about men who wants to come
on here he's coming on soon oh he is
yeah he tried to get him last week but
you were gone and then I was sick so it
was kind of just like a no-go but he's
got a great bit about how uh he's
talking about men and women and how
women don't do sound effects he's like
I've never heard a woman do a sound
effects you know guys come in with a
story they're like
you know if you've never seen a woman do
that I was like that is such a great
observation I love a good observation
brilliant brilliant so true weird when
it's like it feels so good when you
notice something too that you're just
like oh no one's noticed this I know I
love that I mean that's like half
sometimes you the the observation is
like the hard part is then having a bit
um well [ __ ] this up this observation's
so good how do I follow this exactly
because you almost can't even follow how
good the observation is with a joke and
it's harder to catch an observation when
it's something you never see you know
you see oh this happens a lot but if
it's like you never see a woman make
sense you're like oh yeah it's all it's
harder to notice the ones that don't
happen that aren't there yeah which is
even more impressive yeah no then you go
the actor that's a good one though
that's a great yeah where you guys at
with act outs because I was with a comic
and he was like I've got three act outs
I'm trying to get it down to two and I
was like why it works yeah it works I
mean you don't want to be doing
backflips as your punch lines I guess
but if it works I'm a big fan of uh
humping stools
no I think if it depends on your act
obviously right like for someone like me
I'm not a big act out guy but then when
you do one it sometimes hits harder
because you don't normally do it right
you know like sometimes you like heard
like an old Nick de Paulo album or
something he'll do a sound effect out of
nowhere and you're like oh I didn't know
he could do that yeah it's like it's an
even bigger laugh totally totally style
change yeah but if it's if that's the
whole act it's not my it's not my
personal preference but there are people
who are great at it so it is it can be
really good but three in an hour is not
too much for no I think it all depends
on your act no of course not I mean how
many actors does prior do and they're
great yeah so if you're great at it then
you're great at it yeah you know uh
uh this is I got a couple peeps here
first love it do you you ever get this
one this is kind of similar to yours
uh where do they go uh so I'm in Buffalo
and they go oh you live in New York City
oh yeah yeah do you know do you know Bob
Johnson I don't know Bob all right what
about Rick Simpson I'm like no I don't
know and they keep asking me if I know
people who live in a certain town or
like you were just in San Francisco
comics
I don't think so there's like oh you
know this guy because he also lives in
New York or I'm going to San Francisco
oh oh you're going there yeah you've
been there before you know uh Chet
Sanders I'm like I don't know I don't
know anybody and now you feel like an
[ __ ] cause you keep turning the guy
down you're like no no I don't even know
what [ __ ] yeah we need a ched in the
rotation jets are tough chats are hard
to find well that's the bully and Weird
Science [ __ ] [ __ ] it was like the scary
white guy
he's funny uh
yeah that's a weird one I I don't like
and also it's like do you know what the
population in New York is I know exactly
because that because the thing is you go
to some of these small towns and they do
know everybody like I had a you know we
were in Springfield Missouri and my
friend uh Liam Nelson is opening and he
has all these girls coming to see him
tall kid he's like seven feet tall and
all these girls come out to see him with
the show he's hosting
and the guy goes he said let me see a
picture of her he goes I might have
[ __ ] her that's how small the town is
yeah and he's like I haven't we're like
all right that makes sense small town I
think people just don't know what to say
so like oh New York I I know a guy maybe
you know him we can connect on that but
now I just feel bad because I keep
saying no I don't know him no I don't
know him like assume I know no one tell
the story it is weird I mean New York is
why would you know just a random person
if it's in your field I get it because
Comics right sure
but yeah that's a that's a definite
annoying peeve brutally annoying and and
I think he was also trying to show me
that he knew a lot of people he's like
oh I'm friends with this guy you know
him what about this guy he works for hit
you know that guy I don't know anybody
before we go have you ever seen this
Chet Hank's clip oh it's great he was on
z-way and she tried to get him to
apologize for his Jamaican accent he
does like a fantastic to make an accent
oh does it I mean like spot on anyway
she tried to get him apologized for it
give me a louder
hold on can you make that ladder Peters
I can't really hear it I'm sorry all
right uh-oh this is bombing worse than a
Franklin clip Franken [ __ ] huh all right
that was a big huh all right never mind
yeah that's a great clip I've seen it
it's really funny yeah he's an
interesting guy oh yeah is his mom Rita
Wilson
I don't think so oh are there other
hanks's I thought it was a nuclear
family like she would set this straight
nope it's his mom oh it is his mom yeah
wow uh-huh but Colin Hanks that's not
his mom right he looks just like Tom and
a hell of an actor Colin he's really
good he's good Orange County was
underrated oh yeah great cast too you
got like John Lithgow Catherine O'Hara
Jack Black obviously but I'm like damn
this is like kind of a stacked that's
true comedy cast was that fairly
I don't think it was fair but they had a
[ __ ] run uh Orange County yeah they
had underrated
then they came around and did green book
green book
um is that right yeah yeah he has
another one out with uh Woody Harrelson
his hope coaching a team of mentally
challenged kids and I'm like all right
this is this is a tightrope watch yeah
Jay kastin I wonder if that's uh oh he's
done a lot of [ __ ] casting son he is
really yeah Lawrence casting writing
extraordinaire hey there we go white
whoa
oh yeah
he's also in School of Rock that's a
that's another great one another great
one dude who that's like Jack Black's
greatness where you're like how many
people can have done that role well
exactly he [ __ ] killed that was like
right after high fidelity I feel like
yeah break out but then School of Rock
it was like oh you're a [ __ ] star
dude yeah man he killed it he really
popped and then I feel like he's kind of
fizzled no he's he's [ __ ] he was in
the Jumanji movies he's in Tropic
Thunder isn't it oh yeah pull up do you
see the clip of him in the new Weird Al
movie oh did you see that I just watched
a few Clips my friend sent was showing
me the clips they're so [ __ ] funny I
got a I'm a huge Weird Al fan dude pull
up just go to like two minutes into uh
are we allowed to play this Peters or no
all right uh go to Another One Rides the
Bus because Jack Black's in the scene
is it no no no go to go to Weird Al
movies Weird Al movie Another One Rides
the Bus it's [ __ ] incredibly funny
how they do this so apparently the
movie's very tongue-in-cheek like
they're doing all the tropes all the
cliches they're mocking the biopic
exactly every clip I've seen is I gotta
watch the whole movie it looks hilarious
um I grew up loving this guy me too dude
eat it yeah this is the scene I think
but can we get better quality this is
uh-oh
why is the audio working yeah [ __ ] it
why are we oh [ __ ]
is this gonna work with our guest later
our guess is not going to
oh that's headphones oh maybe we have to
put headphones on
nothing
all right well I got one more P while
you queefs are doing the tech how about
this
and this is this is where I become a
[ __ ] but you ever walk into a restaurant
and right before you open the door a
group walks in right in front of you and
it throws your whole Chipotle day off
because they gotta go in the line and
they go what do you have here oh
Justin almost in front of you and now my
whole day you knew what you wanted yes
the slow order sliding in oh the slide
in the same same thing when you're
trying to get in the on the you know oh
here it is yeah you got it now
he challenged them to write a song off
the cuff and says you can't do it and
that's the guy from Queen the bass
player oh wow so we said you can't come
up with a song for another one uh bites
the dust
[Music]
in the back
yes
[Music]
[Music]
Conan
I know the One Rides the Bus Another One
Rides the Bus Stop
[Music]
[Music]
yeah he's so funny yeah no we were at
the Rose remember we went to this roast
that's right Schumer brought us that's
right that was fun that was fun that was
kind of old school it was Midtown a lot
of old uh roaster guys there that was
awesome yeah to go off your peeve though
I mean the guy who slides in front and
doesn't know what the [ __ ] this is a
city where you better know what the [ __ ]
you want and you know how to do [ __ ]
when you're trying to get on the subway
and the guy slides in then they just
it's always a dude who doesn't know how
to work a metro card
and you're like I had it yeah I [ __ ]
had it exactly it's kind of like when
you go to the grocery and some guy's got
900 carts and you're like dude I got one
pair let me get through with the pair
and he's like all right you go with the
pair they should be allowed to do that
with restaurants like hey I know what I
want I'm in I'm out I'm a pro you've
never been to
uh was it just a salad or whatever the
hell this place is called
sweet green
it's it is it's just lack of awareness
like you ever see the guy on the uh like
I saw the other day it was it was
raining it wasn't like super hard but it
was hard enough to be annoying three
people in a row they all have umbrellas
they're blocking the whole street and I
just watch a person trying to get around
them the whole time and it was it was
like a chaplain thing this woman was
just like just like so annoying she's
like right and they didn't even notice
her it was hilarious oh that's good
stuff these umbrella people are they're
menaces somebody walking by and go
straight up I go you guys got it or they
and then the people that they try to
like weave through people with the
umbrella I'm like that's a sharp thing
oh yeah you take out a [ __ ] eye with
that thing I know I know now everybody
else everybody else ends up bobbing and
weaving for your umbrella
all right last one love these peeps
though how about this guy the guy who
can't answer a question with a yes or no
he go uh what are you from uh you're
from Denver he goes well
you know it's a long story uh I actually
was
my parents they met in Saigon you know
at 88 and I'm like get to it all I did I
was done yes or no you got me you had me
it's a long story oh that's a peeve it's
a long story what do you think this is
you're [ __ ] coming out party just
[ __ ] tell the story and don't even
really give a [ __ ] about where you're
from I was just trying to make a small
talk but you've made a big talk it's a
long story what is this a 10 part
Netflix uh Series yeah don't making a
murderer this [ __ ] just tell me the
[ __ ] story give me the trailer of the
story trailer More Trailers less full
Parts Series right it's like your bit
with the uh the Youtube where I want to
tap the guys for like let me just get to
the meat of this here I don't need the
full parents meeting and it was
everything I'm like how much time you
doing he's like
well you know I have like 40. I'm like
just say 20 30 10 I don't even know how
much time you have to tell these people
you're opening for you you know there's
another one it's like I always want to
do it but I never did this but like
about how the uh
you ever tell like someone's telling a
story and you're just like oh my God and
it's like it's like an Uber it's like
you're calling it oh yeah and then
you're like how long is this gonna be
and then it's like it's like when you
look down you think it's gonna be like
four minutes because you look down
you're like now it's nine minutes not
Ruby has a joke about that really yeah
yeah this was like years ago I wrote
this premise I never I never did [ __ ]
with it but it was like I was like oh it
says like
I don't know he said the only way I can
explain to you how time lapses when
you're doing mushrooms is like you're
looking at your Uber app and your Uber
says it'll be there in four minutes and
you wait three minutes look about it it
says six minutes uh you're like how does
this possible time travel yeah see Uber
is a [ __ ] guzzler because if you're not
ready when the Uber's there they cancel
they charge it but they can just keep
going up in time I'm like you said six
minutes at 11 11. oh and they canceling
you all the time and then they cancel on
you but I get five dollars exactly yes
where's your penalty
no penalty no penalty what's good for
the goose is good for the gander
is that the right expression I've heard
that I think
I got another wreck all right we're in
wreck peeve mode because it's been a
while since it's just been yes we're
loaded up I was watching TV the other
day Almost Famous comes on oh that's a
great movie great movie that's really
dude and Philip Seymour Hoffman in that
movie holy [ __ ] amazing yeah so good
golden god lock the gates uh Penny Lane
Marin yeah so good that movie you you
feel it you're that's a real Cameron
Crow she's wonderful in it kills it Kate
Hudson is so good oh it's a great move
that's her Peak I think I think that's
where she peaked yeah yeah well she was
in a lot of bad movies after that but
she still she'll be her Pizza yeah yeah
no I agree I mean no but when you do it
when you do a shitload of like big
commercial Blockbusters I mean yeah they
all this was like an artistic Peak okay
how to lose a career in 10 days but yeah
I think she's doing all right she's
doing I'm joking but I gotta think for
her and her mom isn't that fun when you
want to [ __ ] both if you still want to
[ __ ] oh yeah
how old is he it's got to be 90.
I would definitely take old Goldie oh
look here up
yeah yeah I've done worse you take a
Goldie shower
but yeah that's good she looks like a
Bruce Valance but yeah I'm not uh I'm
not opposed
she's got the big I love a big old mouth
she got she got implants over the years
a mouth implant no no uh I'm gonna give
her a mountain
blissom breast implants these things
yeah and is she still with Kurt
wow that gives you hope huh he's a hunk
that's a cool that's a cool Hollywood
marriage great couple hopefully he
doesn't listen to this podcast or he's
gonna go hateful eight on your ass
hateful 80.
did we get an age oh I'm sorry no
but yeah she looks I would still do her
I do obviously I do Kate
77. oh she's up there hey uh underrated
a good chick flick every once there's a
chick flick that's actually a good chick
oh yeah First Wives Club really solid
Peters Salamanca anyone what do you
think Goldie uh Diane Keaton and Midler
Midler hey that's a good Trio
96. I think it was pretty funny yeah
I've actually never seen it is that a no
it looks like a nor Ephron
um all right all right we got a lot of
range I got another uh oh no don't play
The Whole Trailer what happened how did
we get the audio going though now the uh
I gotta did I mention the Fatty Arbuckle
thing last week with Ari or no oh I love
Fatty Arbuckle did I mention this
book called frame up about Rosco Fatty
Arbuckle yeah the trial about how he was
like [ __ ] over in his career was ended
and he didn't do this is the most
cinematic book I've ever read I'm like
how it's really up in a movie the
stories are insane it's like literally
you know the worst childhood horrible
horrible dad and uh there's a story
about him going to uh he goes takes a
long long train ride to go live with his
dad after his mom dies and he's if you
don't know who he is he was a big silent
movie star the biggest silent movie star
highest most highest paid before he was
framed for killing a woman maybe the
first book is a movie star he was the
fat guy he was yeah he invented the pie
throw wow isn't that crazy and it's
hilarious the way they write about it
like fatty could throw pies all sorts of
ways behind the back yeah like he could
all do he could do all kinds of throws
but uh he's a kid he's like a child it's
like the most tragic childhood oh yeah
he tricks it it takes a train ride to
see his dad his dadagus owned this hotel
and he went there to go see his dad
after his mom died and when he gets
there the dad had fled town because he
heard his son was coming he sold the
hotel so he goes in there and they're
like oh poor kid so they feed him and
they're like laughing at how much he
eats and then they have a talent show
one night and he goes on and sings and
they're like holy [ __ ] and then he's got
an opera voice he's incredible and well
of course it's like classic Showbiz once
he starts blowing up the dad is like
Sonny Boy
wow it's so dark but uh yeah crazy and
by the way a woman that he did all these
movies with her name Mabel Normand whoa
whoa crazy I mean all the stories like
the studio head was [ __ ] her and then
uh you know it was on and off again he
never fully commit to her and she walks
in on him with another woman and hits
her head and had to have like surgery
and she was never the same she hit the
Other Woman No it hit her in the head oh
something landed on her she hit her head
somehow wasn't completely clear but
she's never the same so what's the frame
up is it the bottle incident the rape
thing yeah what's how was he framed I
don't know I'm not even finished yet I'm
like I'm like 150 pages in but it's
great where's that movie by the way they
should make a movie it was supposed to
be Chris Farley oh oh that would be
something but it was a it was like a
Hollywood party is what I think and and
let me finish the book and I'll tell you
crazy that just started this and it's
great the the links the dad went to hide
from the Sun selling a hotel and all
that [ __ ] terrible person insane it's a
kid you could just say oh he's full of
[ __ ] he's yeah shout out Dana ghoul for
telling me to pick this one up it's a
good one Ellie he's obsessed with the
story great comedian Dana Gould followed
he's been posting Great Clips on
Instagram you sent me one the other day
it's so good so I love the Gould one of
the best guys get them on here oh that'd
be great oh yeah and The Simpsons just
that guy's got such a resume great
resume by the way I've been watching
Family Guy it's amazing what they get
away with yeah they are dark which one
which clip oh well there's so many but I
just saw the one where it's like the
Olympics and it's a you know row of
Runners and they shoot the gun and all
the white guys take off and they're like
hey look at us we're doing great and
then the black guy's like all right I
guess we should start now and then they
take off and the white guys are like
they're gonna get our wallets yeah
three other jokes I'm forgetting but
good stuff
yeah I remember it's funny but black
dudes love that show oh yeah remember we
watch it we'd uh you know I went to
Sixers basketball camp in Philly when I
was like 17 I went for like a week and
we all just like in this bunk with one
TV and we and we would just watch Family
Guy every night before bed and it would
[ __ ] murder oh it's not like I've
never seen people laugh at this [ __ ]
like it was like it was like back in the
day when you go to a movie theater yeah
there aren't many movie comedy movies
you go to a theater and get the laugh I
love it you know what movie I just saw
that's killer
the Banshees of innishirin oh I'm dot
Colin Farrell yeah he's phenomenal and
Brandon Gleason it's that playwright
Martin McDonough who made all those
plays uh you know pillow man uh [ __ ]
of anishman the the beauty queen of uh
lenaine I'm sorry if I'm butchering the
names yeah it's it's it's dark as [ __ ]
oh yeah is it funny like the other one
yeah it's funny great it's weird and
funny and uncomfortable as hell with my
mom and she was like she was laughing
really hard oh [ __ ] and I was like I was
apart from I was like this is funny dude
what let's get this clip real quick
because this is a classic oh what is
this excuse me ma'am no porn at the bar
oh it's okay I'm transgender oh I I had
no idea do whatever you want all the
time oh my God it's okay do whatever you
want all the time
that's comedy for you folks they really
they really get it for Fox yeah oh yeah
their grandfathered in they are it's
like South Park Family Guy they're like
kind of just like this is sorry this is
what we do well once you throw it
Married with Children out there 20 years
ago we were like all right we're out you
guys just run the Asylum we can't even
touch the [ __ ] so good
it does seem like there's a sad thing
now and look it's you could look at it
either way but a lot of people are going
back to Seinfeld going back to the
office the office like the number one
show and it's 25 years old or whatever
the hell it is maybe 20 10. but it feels
like we got to go back a little bit to
see some comedy sometimes and that's a
bummer I guess stand-up is really moving
I don't like all these articles were
like wasn't there the viral thing with
Mindy Campbell yeah all these characters
would be canceled I'm like they're
characters I know and you wrote them but
you're rich off of it but it just weird
to me when we're like these characters
would be canceled it's like yeah that's
we're laughing at the character right
exactly I don't get why this is yeah
that's a great point it's so strange to
be strange it's like
um All In The Family the number one show
in the world hilarious show we're
laughing because the guy's a fat idiot
like he's a racist bigot and we're
laughing at him yeah that's part of the
fun
yeah I mean it's uh it's weird how we
have to and and you just see how much
the goal post is like coming it's like
more in the last 10 years probably than
in any 10-year period oh yeah
comedically for sure I mean social media
I assume because now everybody can be
like no no and then corporations like
all right that's what it is we don't get
in trouble yeah they're they're more
scared than ever but whatever I mean
we're we're having fun and we're that's
why it's great to be a comic you really
can do whatever you want yeah and first
for the next whatever two years this
podcast [ __ ] lasts and then then we'll
be out on the street by the way 100 000
Subs
hell yeah that's what Fatty Arbuckle ate
all right Buffalo uh I mean Buffalo I
almost said Buffalo Trace Bodega cat
whiskey yeah suck at Buffalo
tracewhiskey.com hey this is this is
going to be everywhere in the new year
so get ready it's already it's specs and
all all specs in Texas
liquor store Bodega whiskey.com we're
everywhere everywhere uh I mean it's
this is good whiskey hell yeah get some
quick get on the patreon and I'm a
little excited and nervous about our
guests this is this guy's a big get
we've never done a big fish but he's in
LA and we figured you know we just had a
special come out it'd be cool to have
him on so he's our
mark
s the Italian himself Sebastian
Maniscalco so uh we'll be back in a
minute with uh with Sebastian so oh yeah
with us welcome to to Hoodie hour with
Mark and Sam wait do we do we cut
hey folks this show is sponsored by
better help when you're on top of the
world you can do great things but if
life gets you bogged down and you can't
do anything you feel overwhelmed work
with a therapist makes you more prepared
to take on everything life throws at you
we love therapy we're in therapy highly
recommended get the garbage out it's
building up in your head you can't
Fester everybody's festered about
something I don't care who you are Kanye
or anybody else better help us
convenient flexible affordable entirely
online fill out a brief questionnaire
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge easy peasy tell them
how to do it if you want to live a more
empowered life Kanye therapists can get
you there visit betterhelp.com drunk
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash drunk
yes start off 2023 with your own
personal chef Factor shops preps cooks
and deliveries to your door so you can
enjoy Chef crafted dietitian approved
minus the hassle these fresh never
frozen meals are delicious and
nutritious we love these guys they're
Chef's Choice options always taste great
they're simple like Kanye and with
calorie smart and keto options facto
meals are perfectly portioned to keep
you on track with your goals Factor now
offers over 34 meals per week and over
three dozen add-on options each factor
meal arrives pre-prepared by their team
of chefs ready to heat and eat in just
two minutes tell them how Mark go to
factor75.com
drunk60 use code drunk 60 to get 60 off
your first box that's drunk60 at go Dot
factor75.com
60 to get six percent off your first box
get on it
oh you got the hoodie memo
oh look at that
look at us
all right that was the last fart
uh let us know Peters will start start
going
hey hey folks here we are with our first
Zoom guest uh we're honored to have you
we're big fans Sebastian Maniscalco
everybody
what's up what's up so do you normally
do this on uh was there an option to
come sit on the couch with you guys yeah
yeah we're in New York we'd love to have
you oh you're in New York you're in New
York okay now if you're in New York come
by and uh and have a drink with us uh we
got a full bar you know
oh yeah we're alcoholics
do you drink Sebastian yeah yeah what's
your drink
I'm a wine guy but if I'm not doing wine
I'll I'll have a tequila on the Rocks
but that's kind of where I live in those
two neighborhoods yeah well you're so
busy you can't be hungover anymore
but you have a full day I feel like
every you must especially now with like
a special out you're doing there's a
there's a full-on I see you everywhere
I'm like I turn my TV I'm like CBS
Sunday Morning Sebastian everywhere so
is that exhausting right now
well you know what I I
I'm not really busy right now I mean I
kind of did all that press leading up to
the release of the special but now I'm
just chilling out hanging out at the
house I got two small kids five and
three so uh yeah right now right now
it's not a busy time for me it was but
uh I'm taking some time off touring with
him but take about a year and a half off
and and and just kind of relax live my
life a little bit because I've been kind
of burning
uh with touring for the last day you
know the only time I took off was really
covered so now it's time to take off
again yeah I mean please take off
because we have the same manager and I
just they keep comparing me to you like
well Sebastian did about 38 shows on
Saturday and I'm like come on I can't
move the tickets it's a little different
yeah
um no it's not it's not a pressure to
sell tickets you know when you're out
there you always want to like you know
fill the room make sure uh people are
buying tickets uh so yeah it's a little
nerve-wracking yeah I mean I saw you at
the Garden I don't know when this eight
months ago and then you did the Barclays
and then you did Prudential in Jersey
it's like this guy's an animal I don't
know there's that many guineas in this
tri-state area
I'm on you man I'm pulling them out of
the basement yeah
I come to town uh the whole Italian
Community apparently comes out which you
know is is nice I mean it's been you
know I did a couple jokes early on in my
special that I didn't really know who
would land because I thought they were
too specific to the Italian Community
and I'm really glad I did because it
brought a lot of those people out to the
shows uh so uh yeah the Italian I got
the Italians on lockdown oh yeah and the
Jewish wife that doesn't hurt
hey you know you bring the Jews over too
and you got a nice little Arena oh yeah
oh yeah what do you or Temple
uh your rise was kind of old school and
kind of quiet I remember like
when you first started selling out of
clubs I would hear about it and I'd be
like I'd be like oh I've never I don't
know this guy yet and they'd be like oh
he sold out this many shows I was like
oh wow it was the first thing that
really popped you up was it uh the Vince
Vaughn comedy thing
so when I did that uh that that came out
in 2008 and that kind of uh launched me
into just headlining clubs for
yeah what I think it was like a thousand
dollars a week or fifteen hundred
dollars a week whatever the the pay was
and I got to quit my job waiting tables
and uh that's kind of what put me into
just working as a comedian and then you
know every year you know you guys know
you do a club and then the next year you
go back to the club and more people come
and you know it just kind of happens
over a course of for me it was about 10
to 12 years just kind of hitting the
club scene and and and really working at
it and then uh yeah so you're right
there was no like big TV film or
anything that kind of launched my career
stand up was just kind of all just doing
stand-up comedy that's impressive
it's very it's very old school it's it's
a few people like that I mean it's like
you there's Gaff again there's you know
there's Regan Burr is like that I feel
like I mean but they're it's hard not to
blow up these days without something
else yeah
well especially now with these podcasts
you know a lot of people uh do a podcast
it becomes extremely popular and if
they're stand-up comedians they then
they tour off the the shoulders of their
podcast and the podcast listeners come
out to see them do stand-ups so I think
that when I came up I started in 1998
there was really no other outlets for
comedians I mean social media wasn't as
big as it was now so the way I just went
about it was if I'm gonna be a comedian
I'm gonna have to get up on stage every
night and kind of work at this and
um and that's that's kind of the way but
but now it's it's a whole different game
I mean you got
you got people calling themselves
comedians uh when I hear the word
comedian I don't know how you guys look
at this I just I just think of stand up
right
I don't think of like you're funny
because you're doing something on your
Instagram page I just I look at it as
strictly stand up but comedian I think
over the last five to seven years have
become very Broad and uh there's a lot
of different opportunities for people
who are funny uh that are excelling
through these channels and platforms
that maybe weren't readily available 20
25 years ago totally like you know Will
Ferrell obviously a hilarious guy tried
stand up and was like this is too hard
and I I'd love that I secretly selfishly
I'm like hell yeah [ __ ] you can't do
this [ __ ] we're in the trenches it's
hell we're getting heckled to drunks
check spot chicken wings come on does
any party you miss that now that you're
you're doing Arenas and stuff is any
part of you like man it was It was kind
of fun fending off drunks Late Show in
Tampa is any party you miss it oh no I
love the comedy club experience uh I I
think uh that's the way comedy should be
enjoyed in a you know Comedy Club 200
people 250 people whatever it is uh you
know you lose a lot of that intimacy
once you start doing a theater or Arena
you don't have that kind of connection
you might have with a small group of
people so yeah I mean you know I live
out in Los Angeles love going to The
Comedy Store while I'm here and working
stuff out those those nights are
actually the most enjoyable nights for
me is the kind of Comedy Club working
out the material opposed to you know
showcasing it in front of a large
audience I I still like the comedy club
uh days yeah I mean I used to see you at
Gotham and mozilli the owner of Gotham
would always tap me and go like this
guy's the biggest guy no one's ever
heard of huge and you would sell out
like six shows
yeah Gotham was uh one of those clubs
that was I don't know it was really good
to me and then I would I didn't even
like I was a little uh apprehensive to
move on to a theater crowd because I'm
like I don't even you know I'm selling
out a comedy club but I don't know if I
could sell out a theater you know and I
was uh I wanted to stay in the comedy
clubs as long as I possibly could
but it got to be a little bit tiring you
know doing two shows a night right for
six seven nights it was just a little
too too taxing not not like I'm breaking
concrete but you know just you know when
you're talking up there for you know two
shows a night your voice you know gets
gets shot so
um but yeah the comedy club is there's
no better experience and you're also
performing I mean you're like really
good on the show I mean I told my agent
I was sick as hell in Phoenix uh a few
weeks ago and I did the shows this is
how I perform I talk like this this is
it it's monotone it's no performance I
said like if I were Sebastian this
weekend would have been [ __ ] if I had
to actually perform and do real you know
because your new special is one thing I
really like about it is like you're like
an old school guy you're in Vegas you
it's old Vegas the vibe you get people
in the crowd to dress up yeah there's
something really old time like almost at
a place in time about it you know
yeah I've always been an older Soul you
know growing up even in my early 20s I
was you know I just felt like I was
older than my years and for this new
special I decided oh you know what
entertainment to me has kind of
I don't know it used to be like a
something about it when I was growing up
and I was watching uh whether it be a
performer singer a comedian whatever it
just seemed like
even before even I should say not
growing up before
the 50s the 60s seemed like it was just
uh
entertainment was like man where where
is Hollywood it didn't even look like it
was a a real place and there was like a
Mystique about it and I think over the
years that Mystique has kind of been
lost and I was like oh you know it'd be
cool to kind of pay homage to that time
by doing a special wearing a tuxedo I
was a little I don't normally perform in
a tuxedo and it was a little
um
I wasn't as physical as I normally am
just because of it was a little
restricting performing in a in a plus I
I I I was uh I had gained some weight
and
and before me in the tuxedo is tight so
um yeah it was a little bit more a
different vibe than I normally would do
but you know it's as performers and you
guys well know it's like sometimes you
get a little bored doing kind of the
same thing day in and day out you want
to mix it up you want to try new things
and uh yeah I just kind of like evolving
as a comedian here here yeah I just got
married so I also know what it's like to
perform on a tuxedo but let me just say
this
we got a connection here and I uh I
gotta ask you about this because I only
share this with a few people
Jerry is a fan Seinfeld I think he likes
me I'm too scared to text him what
what's your move I want to I want to
build a bond with him but I I can't I
don't want to bother him
I wrestled with this aha
so you're not alone thank you
I don't think Jerry Seinfeld is much of
a texter oh
um not that you will not get a text back
but I feel like talk about old school
this guy's like a I want to talk to you
right
um
so
yeah I in the beginning of our
relationship with I I didn't know what
was appropriate right like
like can I go hey did you see the game
it's like it's like a hot chick yeah we
were just like I just don't [ __ ] this up
don't [ __ ] this up but yeah yeah exactly
it's a good analysis is he when he came
to your show I remember being a Gotham
too and Chris mazzilli was like Seinfeld
came to see Sebastian the other night
whoa that's huge what is that were there
people that come to your show does it
ever throw you off when it's someone
like that or are you ever a little extra
nervous
well when he came I was actually excited
because you know I've been a big fan of
Seinfeld since I was a kid so when he
was in the room I wanted to you know
make sure that
I brought my not that I don't bring my a
game but like when he was there on my
military Seinfeld's here I'm gonna smack
him in the mouth with this material uh
so for him it was a little bit more like
excitement
um sometimes when somebody's in the
crowd
uh I I can't say that I I worry about it
I I don't I don't really worry about it
no
all right but do you still chat with him
I was in his mood
well yeah he who what do you play in the
in the movie I play a security guard at
the uh Pop Tart it's about it's about
Pop-Tarts right
I'm a security guard at the Pop-Tart
Factory and when I went in
uh again I'm I'm a little nervous doing
movie roles just because that's not what
I do day in and day out
now I go to the set
I sit down and he's directing and he's
also starring in it so the scene head
himself myself Jim Gaffigan was in the
scene and I start doing the lines and he
would say cut you you flood the line and
now now in my in my head I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm I'm screwing this up
like what did I say he goes
you said guy
and the word is man I just I just would
I said it like I would probably normally
say it
but here's the thing about Seinfeld
He Wants It Word Perfect
how it's written is how you say it and I
was screwing up the lines because I was
just doing it the way I would normally
say it I start getting in my head and I
start sweating now I'm sweating nervous
and uh
I'm starting to smell like Bo oh
now I don't smell I don't have Bo I've
never had it
I don't wear deodorant I just don't
admit odor when I sweat
so at lunch I went in and I talked to
the Wardrobe and I go I don't know if
you've ever heard this before but I
think the jacket that I got on has Bill
and he goes no it's an older jacket
because it's a a period piece so it's
like it takes place in the 60s so I'm
wearing like this tweed jacket and sure
enough he's like we've heard about this
let me blast the jacket with this like
commercial uh grade spray I'll leave it
out in the sun and maybe that will do it
so I put it back on again it didn't do
anything it still smelt so I had to tell
Seinfeld and the rest of the actors
listen if you start smelling beef
it ain't me it's the it's the jacket so
uh
yeah so that's the last time I spoke to
Seinfeld there hasn't been really any
communication but if I were you I would
maybe start picking up the phone and
giving them a shout what's going on
how's it going because he loves to talk
comedy right okay no it just feels bold
to just hey Ring Ring Hey Jer to our
generation to this Bulls yeah maybe
someone calls me I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you doing yeah I wanna yeah right
but
but if Jerry Seinfeld called you would
you go what the [ __ ] are you doing no
punched my wife and kick her down the
stairs and answer the phone
I say you go with the call man because
the texting you're not gonna get much
okay
this is big but that's gonna take I'm
gonna have to prepare for three hours
meditate take a walk have a list of
topics
well if there's a reason to call I would
say you don't just call and ask what's
going on I would call and ask them what
like a specific question or because you
know what this guy's been through it all
on the stand-up side and the TV side so
having him as a friend and kind of a
mentor is really a real add value in
your life just because if you ever had a
question about anything in regards to
stand up what a guy to have in your
pocket to talk about it totally no I'm
I'm honored just the fact that he knows
my name is insane uh one last question
or whatever I don't know how much time
we have but
love the special I felt like you've done
how many now
uh that was my sixth special wow this
one felt like you were the most
uh opened you opened up like you let the
crowd into who you were more than you
because you're so observational but this
one I felt like you kind of like all
right I'm being me screw it
yeah I think that's just growing up and
being you know evolving as a comedian
and being extremely comfortable on stage
to like share things that maybe you
weren't able to share 10 years ago uh
you know maybe shed some light on some
some uh of what's going on in the world
and and poke fun at it or or uh yeah so
I appreciate you saying that it was you
know still growing as a comedian still
learning and uh still trying to
challenge myself so uh you hope you hope
people enjoy it you know uh
as a comedian when you put out these
specials we hope it does better or
people like it right
more than they did the others but you
know and I'm not a big review guy I
don't look at a lot of things that what
people say or or whatnot but I skimmed
some of the comments on this special and
I noticed like some of the core fans
were like oh we like when you are a
little bit more physical or or animated
this one we didn't really care for that
much but I think in
the course of a career and I actually
heard this from Judd Apatow last night
that it takes 10 years for something to
find its legs you know you can judge it
right now and or anything like a movie
but maybe when you watch the same movie
10 years from now it has a different
effect on people so I don't think it's
you know
I don't know you just put it out there
and and however it lives it lives yeah
and you got to do you I mean Bill Burr
saw the the he said that about George
Carlin he's like this guy would reinvent
every special and he's like I don't care
if you're coming with me this is kind of
who I am
yeah I think and also you're kind of
you're getting you are kind you don't
have to look at reviews when you are
focused testing this material by touring
throughout the group right you're
getting a read I mean this you do it
long enough we have a thing on this show
we Mark and I complain a lot a lot of
pet peeves a lot of your stand up is pet
peeve yeah you have a lot of complaints
about the world one that sticks out to
me which I can't believe it's never made
it on here is you used to do a bit about
dudes and flip-flops
are there any any pet peeves recently
that just about humans that just bother
you
uh
uh you know what bothers me and I don't
know if you're picking this up as we're
talking here
ring lights
[Laughter]
I'm not into Pete I got one on right now
but I I I don't like it when I'm
watching something and I could see the
ring light in the person's eyeball oh
yeah
bothers me
I can see that
another thing that bothers me is face
timing in public with no earphones crazy
that's a great piece should be killed in
the street psychos who is that
uh
I don't know I just I I don't know I
think there's got got to be like a
technology edit uh etiquette class
implemented into the public school
system
teaching kids how to you know uh behave
with technology and what's appropriate
uh moving forward yeah I was on a flight
in the day the guy's doing the music
just on his phone no headphone it wasn't
even like listen quietly just full blast
you're like there's other people around
what do you think this is oh it's even
more awful I've had the guy do the
FaceTime next to me without headphones
and I was like I'm I can't move
I can't move away from you I'm stuck
listening to your [ __ ] on a conversation
yeah I mean at least if they're doing
the street which it's still awful right
you can get away true the hostage the
hostage situation public Face Time
inexcusable yeah awful
I agree I gotta ask you too I mean
you're you got a movie coming out
De Niro's playing your dad I'm sure
you've been asked this to death but I
mean
first off insane and second off like any
good De Niro stories
so
um well De Niro wanted to talk to my
father because he's the the it's
autobiographical the movie
um it's basically uh
it's a love letter to my father
and and the Nero wanted to talk to my
dad
uh about you know how he holds his cigar
how he wears his hat what does he do
when he's cutting hair because my hair
that's a beautician
so he said uh I want them on set
for the movie now my dad is still
cutting hair he's 76 and he's still
cutting hair
so he goes to the set and De Niro wanted
him close by now my dad is like
I gotta go back home
and work
so uh my my dad uh and De Niro kind of
became I want to say friends but you
know they had like a you know he spent
three days with him in Oklahoma he spent
some time with him in Alabama while
we're shooting and uh I'm sitting there
looking at this and I couldn't believe
my dad is teaching Robert De Niro how to
do a die job on this side
I I co-wrote so
yeah it just again when I got into
comedy in 1998 I could have never
imagined that you know De Niro would be
playing my father in a movie which again
was anxiety I had so much anxiety uh
during that whole process because you
know I'm I'm working with arguably one
of the greatest actors of all time and
uh I just want to do do my best so uh
yeah I lost a lot of hair
that's insane and then I'd be so worried
about my dad's a big dork so I'd be
worried about what he would say to
DeNiro you know
uh Cape Fear that was scary
what are you doing to me
yeah I mean that's that's insane and you
had a great part in the Irishman too I
mean oh yeah some comic representation
Sebastian Norden oh yeah yeah was that
was that a thrilling thing to be a part
of
yeah I mean again uh
ironically enough
the first scene the first day I'm
shooting that movie it's in the
Copacabana what they did was they took
Gotham Comedy Club they rented it out
and they changed it into the Copacabana
so that's that scene is actually at
Gotham
so we're talking about where Norton's
playing Don Rickles that scene yeah wow
so that's that Gotham Comedy Club and
I'm and it's the first comedy club that
I ever performed in in New York city so
it was like a like kind of like a full
circle moment where man I started doing
stand up here whatever 15 years ago now
I'm doing a scene in the same club with
the with the Nero and patchy and uh yeah
I mean crazy man come on I was like
I had posters of these guys
growing up and now I'm in a scene with
them it was it was it was really a great
experience it was a it was an acting
lesson too I mean they they really
really kind of helped me through the
whole process oh amazing all right let
me ask you uh we'll wrap it up but
you're doing great multiple specials
selling tons of tickets millionaire is
the wife ever happy
the wife is uh yeah the wife I got an
open the wife is always happy oh my wife
walks around with a smile all day long
it's uh it's me
[Laughter]
I just gotta learn to relax and enjoy
the experience a little bit more uh I
don't know if you guys feel this way uh
sometimes you gotta smell the roses you
can't always be worried about like
what's next or what are we doing next
sometimes you have to enjoy what you're
actually doing because before you know
it it's over and you look back and you
go man I wish I would enjoy that moment
a little bit more right so I'm trying to
be more in the present because I'm a big
thinker I'm always thinking down the
road so that's the uh that's the the the
the the goal moving forward is to be a
little bit more uh just enjoy is it
possible to do that as a comedian though
because I've heard people say that and I
and Mark and I are similar to you it's
very hard for us to take small victories
it's very hard for us to to feel Joy I
think part of it is just like the curse
of living in your head I mean that's
where we come with materials so it's
like you're gonna over analyze [ __ ]
yeah you know it's it's like a blessing
and a curse you know it's what you need
as a tool to be a comedian is the the
constant thinking but then that also
could like uh bite you in the ass if you
are constantly in your head so it's
trying to find I guess that balance
where you know you could uh enjoy life a
little bit more and not constantly uh
hyper focus on things yeah well you're
also a great uh example of someone who
moved to LA and stayed funny
all right sorry I had to get an LA knock
in there
oh okay well I appreciate you guys
having me on the show and uh and for
reaching out so uh yeah that's uh next
time in New York maybe we'll we'll call
Seinfeld and go out for a cup of coffee
or something and come in studio we will
get you some good wine Natty wine or
that whatever wine you like we'll get
tequila we got a bartender here so
whatever you want if you're ever in the
city hell yeah and check out the special
is it me Netflix Vegas tuxedo it's a hot
one
thanks guys I appreciate it have a happy
holiday you too enjoy your time off
got it bye-bye comedy hey folks we did
it that's it uh hot up we got Sebastian
we got uh Road talk peeves I got another
pivot oh please I hit another peeve
people people who say do we have I ever
done this we drink on this so I can
never tell what I've done but uh people
who say yo I might I might [ __ ] around
and uh
and do this
like I might [ __ ] around and watch this
movie later
just watch the movie yeah it's never
that crazy of a thing yo I might [ __ ]
around it's never good either so I never
I might [ __ ] around and volunteer at a
soup
that's true it's never like productive
that's true yeah cause I might [ __ ]
around eat a full Pizza
that's easy it bugs me yeah I know I get
that I might [ __ ] around and read a book
just go do it why do you have to tell me
yeah no I'm with you on that one I might
[ __ ] around get out of here I also hate
when people go uh when you're like hey
do you uh you ever go to the bank today
he's like look I'm not trying to go to
the bank like I'm not trying you didn't
go to the bank
you got to try to go to the bank just go
to the bank you have to try yeah that's
me yeah you want this uh you want this
egg roll hey I'm not trying to get
diabetes Well no one's trying to get
diabetes just do it or don't do it and
by the way Happy New Year to everybody
thank you yes and we might be drunk
we're thankful for Salamanca for Peters
for Gotham Studios
Jamie uh everyone who's a part of this
and uh and for you and for you yeah oh
Jamie had a kid by the way the kid is
out yeah so it's a cute cute little guy
cute so congrats to her and she's
pregnant last time she was here yeah she
covers it well because she was throwing
them back wow yeah she was I was trying
to kill the thing you know yeah didn't
take no apparently
[Laughter]
uh Bodega catwhiskey.com tour we're on
tour I got OKC as my last club before
it's all theaters so it's you know
Austin we added a second there please
come out yeah Austin uh Paramount yeah
that's a great theater New Orleans oh
Austin Dallas Tulsa
I can't read St Louis Dallas St Louis
yeah Vegas Vancouver Vancouver yeah uh
Portland
Seattle Salt Lake City Salt Lake City
New York we just added that one Long
Island Atlantic City it's a great
theater I'm open for Jim Jefferies at
once Michigan Minneapolis Madison
Milwaukee so many more New Haven Boston
out of the third so please uh come out
to that one Miami
orlando.com coming everywhere samuel.com
shows hell yeah all right you heard it
here first folks I'm gonna do a uh
special next year early next year so
I got a bunch of hot rooms coming up I
gotta prepare and polish this son of an
onion so I'll be at Zanies in Nashville
doing a ton of shows Blue Note in Hawaii
and I'm going back to the clubs Miami
Improv Spokane is this the bill back up
Bill back up yeah build back better and
uh what's that comedy at the Carlson I'm
going uh I'm going to the rooms baby I'm
going to Jacksonville I'm doing all the
[ __ ] boxes so you heard it here first
folks I'm coming here buy tickets to one
of the [ __ ] boxes yeah you know you need
to laugh in that horrific City you live
in and I'm coming to it I'll tell you
that right now Rochester you name it
markdormancomedy.com get a Bottle happy
new happy holidays get a get a get a hug
going be grateful bring in the new cheer
let's cool it with the anti-Semitism
thank you Sebastian yes and keep
listening subscribe we're over a hundred
thousand subscribers on YouTube and
you're listening on the audio too so we
appreciate you guys hell yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
[Music]
we might be true
[Music]